على النقيض من الجريمة المزعومة التي
بدأت بتسريبات هادئة
لمعلومات حكومية سرية عبر الإنترنت، تم الكشف عن اعتقال
مشتبه به،
وشاهدت مروحيات إخبارية علنية مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي وهو يعتقل
شابًا يبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا خارج
منزله في ماساتشوستس،
ألقت وزارة العدل اليوم القبض على جاك دوجلاس ديشارا
فيما يتعلق بـ  تحقيق في الإزالة
غير المصرح بها المزعومة للاحتفاظ
ونقل معلومات الدفاع الوطني السرية،
تحدث المدعي العام الأمريكي لمدة دقيقة واحدة فقط
ولكن التسريب نفسه كان
أولوية قصوى منذ أن علمت وزارة الدفاع
به قبل أسبوع تقريبًا، ونحن
نواصل العمل حول هذا الأمر  على مدار الساعة جنبًا إلى جنب
مع الوكالات المشتركة
ومجتمع الاستخبارات
لفهم نطاق
هذه التسريبات وتأثيرها بشكل أفضل، لم تقل الحكومة
الكثير بشكل مباشر عن المشتبه بهم، الأشخاص الذين
تم إطلاعهم على التحقيق، أخبروا شبكة CNN
أن التركيز قد ضاقت على الأشخاص الذين لديهم إمكانية
الوصول إلى الوثائق و
مجموعة Discord للتواصل الاجتماعي حيث تم
نشر الوثائق، وهي تحتوي على تفاصيل حول
الحرب في أوكرانيا والاستخبارات حول كل من
أعداء الولايات المتحدة وحلفاءها، فكيف يمكن لشخص يبلغ من العمر
21 عامًا
الوصول إليها، ويشير نائب السكرتير الصحفي للبنتاغون إلى أن
هذا
عمل إجرامي  ووصفه بأنه انتهاك متعمد، ومن
المهم أن نفهم
أن لدينا مبادئ توجيهية صارمة
لحماية
المعلومات السرية والحساسة. وسيمثل جاك تاشارا
لأول مرة أمام
المحكمة الفيدرالية يوم الجمعة مع
استمرار التحقيق ومراجعة البنتاغون لمن
يمكنه الوصول إلى أسرار البلاد.  أنا
إميلي شميدت التقارير